he ter right now too here's a shot by Dylan
Holloway the first Shi the spoiler for Cory
Perry and he'll funnel one toward the net and
that's covered by Lan the routine victory of
its own a couple weeks later here's forsberg with
a snap shot to save made by Stewart Skinner now a
blast by forsberg another save Skinner and
he'll squeeze it 865 save percentage from
his first 12 since then 93 three and he's
18 of 20 here's Yosi a shot coming Guana
up the longt Dallas star stopped by Skinner
Warren Fogle put one in the middle for nurse
angled up the boards and safely out of Vander
Kane two on two nen Hopkins and Fogle plays
on side feathered toward Fogle but broken up
in siss will drive it up the right hand side
did not get out of andri hard charging toward
the side of the goal Fogle put it around the
boards for Cody CeCe as shot a save lanol and
a juicy rebound and was cleared out of there by
Yosi nurse Gathering himself and now leand
Dr up 22 goals his last 13 against Nashville
McDavid a shot Off The Rush O'Reilly had
it knocked Away by Bard and then in the
mix night second effort manages to grab
the bug dishing off one timer in for bl
by forsberg you need that grip that sand
paper and that leadership in your lineup
I Luke Shen just a guy that comes to play
every night he's going to make you pay every
time you're around the net Harry a shot that
was kicked out by Lan tipped up on the short
glass retrieved by dry sule McDavid inside
dyles po check Lankin it trying to go back
door to dry SLE here's Newen Hopkins looking
for a lane McDavid Hopkins will settle halfway
through the power play 12 and a half to go
scoreless in the first P hen Hopkins Ry subtle
surveying
McDavid nen Hopkins dry inside quick shot score
Newen Hopkins his first goal in 10 games Power
Play marker one- nothing Edmonton what a shot
for is driv to the net has three so they're
always looking great movement here by Evon
in a real tight formation by the Nashville
Predator they want to get the outside not the
inside but they find it the Oilers do on this
beautiful pass Leon D sight on the Newen Hopkins
he changes the angle power play of the ERS teams
will really converge back have to be quick four
straight game the Oilers get the first goal the
preceding F they've been down here's a onetime
a save on fors har kind of stuck back there but
Hollow didn't feel like he had a lane here he
tried to shovel it inside per that was broken
up that was close for the last 13 that one loss
was the last time they played here's a quick
ditch in front one timer and a scrolling save
made by Skinner the power play snapping around
information watch EV vanelis presents and then
he just kind of slips in there so he's looking
back he doesn't really move that much but he
just kind of twists his body to open up gets
the one timer away chops out it against Ry
who snagged it back from one knee finds Yosi
loads fires fought off by Skinner bouncing Puck
side of the net good luck here's Cory Perry down
low in front McLoud tried to stuff it in front
that Perry beautiful short side McLoud inide a
second time tie Columbus for the second longest
streak in the history of the league nurse hits
the line with a shot and a stick save made by
lanol here's McDavid down the right hand side
D getting it back from Newen Hopkins quickly in
front hman and that was swatted away at the last
moment by MCD and then a great lunge by Cole Smith
to force it back through the middle of the ice he
wraps up mdavid took him down they're letting
that go and it's a quick send up by carrier on
both sides L he could have maybe six or seven
penalties whistled in this well right from the
getg go you called it it's been a real checking
game and you saw McDavid he kind of forcely got
underneath there on gole the drop gets it back
from hopk so I think if it's in the battle they're
going to let it go if there's a reach they're
calling it McDavid had it blocked thle McDavid
using a screen from Newen Hopkins gliding back h
l it spot this year he's got 23 to lead the club
gold assists check by Fogle hammered on that save
made by skner nist angles one to Yosi looking for
a lane pressure up top from Fogle forb fired it
off the Blocker of Skinner ahead of St Louis the
Western Conference Chris noblock has not lost
to a Western Conference Team yet 13 and0 B's
penalty killing this year below average 76% in
the lead McDavid new Hopkins crosses D McDavid
D to a one timer score the other step it around
and extend to a two nothing lead and Leon Drive
CLE does what he always does against Nashville
he loves playing against this team doesn't he
he helps him right here you can see it's almost
a double team but he picks it up makes a move
and you can see him draw over KN Miss who thinks
that Puck's going to be up for grabs it opens up
space and when you open up space against this
power play Tick tack toe into the back of the
net beautiful little fake he's going to shoot I
mean lanolin has to respect the fact that McDavid
can take that puck to the net he's got an open
Lane and he finds his number one target he knows
exactly that last spot in the Western
Conference Wild Card race centering pass
shot save made on McLoud lanet wasn't sure he
had it Zone to get a puck out of the Zone good
defense leads the offense and this chance
here a great hman from behind McDavid who
set up that play field that pass that
was broken up takes one for M through
traffic stepped it on that save lanin in
Juicy Rebound in front McDavid bounces it
in he set up the initial pressure and then
he finishes Edmonton 3 Nashville nothing that
shift by that line and you talk about building
on a shift and this team has done this so well
they weather the storm in the Predators and then
once possession in the offensive zone the effort
here by McDavid he clawed through a couple
national predators gets the first shot on that
Zack Hyman right there on the door step creates
that Ruckus and then it's McDavid that picks it
up and elevates in tight just a tremendous job
drilled ofel centering pass newon Hopkins did
not get it out Nashville Won't Die s h this jop
wide then shifted FR by Evangelista and bounced
in finally Nashville breaks through sens will
get the goal and with 635 to play the PRS have
life and that snaps a shutout streak of nearly
160 minutes say it was possession but it was a
little pick pocket on Newen Hopkins and it's
been all night long that up for grabs here it
is a good stick again takes it away on the four
check and then the move to the middle result in
this goal it was Cole that stole the puck just
kind of funn it net watch The Bouncing puck
eventually it finds its way in the net but just
sticks hard caram Off the Wall the little chip
beautiful Evangelistic just O'Reilly checked
by McDavid comes loose Drive subtle trying to
muscle it out he does to Hyman beautiful move
around one man to win the game Zack hman he
does 4-1 Hyman the empty net for his 30th he gets
a little piece of it to deny a clean look on that
play this board work though by Leon dle fishes
the puck out stays strong makes sure it gets
up to H and he chips and charges and makes no
mistake that's a salute to history Rogers play
faithful does their job what an electric
final minute 4-1 Edmonton 16 wins in a row